mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour je voulais commencer par vous
parler du mauvais temps je commence par
vous parler du mauvais temps qui est
l'actualité aujourd'hui je voulais
commencer par vous parler de val d'isère
mais je viens de recevoir un flash de l'
agence france-presse qui me dit que sous
la violence du vent une patinoire
récemment installée dans un quartier de
rennes un mort pas très exactement ce
vient de s'écouler pompiers et policiers
sont sur les lieux on ignore encore s'il
ya des victimes
et je vous parle je suis de val d'isère
où ils nagent et où l'on se demande si
les opérations de dégagement des
touristes pourront être menée
entièrement et bien aujourd'hui un
convoi quitter bourg saint maurice ce
matin pour baliser rétine ce convoi
devait ramener les touristes qui n'ont
pas de voiture d'autre part les
automobiles écart descendants de val
d'isère et de tignes depuis 7h30 ont
commencé à arriver à bourg-saint-maurice
ce matin nos envoyés spéciaux qui était
je vous le rappelle à val d'isère dès le
matin de la catastrophe nous envoyer
d'autres reportages et notamment celui
qui nous montre la descente des corps
des victimes de l'avalanche sur val
d'isère pour la troisième journée
consécutive flotte le drapeau à damier
noir et jaune station bloqué isolé on ne
peut ni monter ni descendre piste
interdite danger d'avalanche peu de
monde donc dans les rues de val d'isère
sauf les sauveteurs toujours affairé
autour du chalet de l'ucp à où les
travaux de déblaiement se poursuivent
malgré les routes bloquer un convoi a pu
passer hier cinq camionnettes amenant de
la vallée les cercueils dans lesquels on
allait placer les 39 victimes de
l'avalanche la petite école basse de la
station avait été transformée en
chapelle ardente
un à un les six recueils allaient être
placées dans les camionnettes qui devait
les conduire dans la soirée dans la
vallée à l'hôpital de
bourg-saint-maurice
à val d'isère un autre problème urgent
pour les autorités les hivernants qui
ont été évacués des chalets menacé on
les a regroupés au centre de la station
notamment dans la salle de cinéma est
fermé car la route sera rouverte enfants
des convois de quart des possibilités
pour déjeuner bah je sais pas on a parlé
d'alain casse-croûte là mais pour le
moment sans manquer de nous mêmes
effectivement dans l'après midi c'est le
ravitaillement il est arrivé vous l'avez
vu avec le convoi venu de laval est
venue de bourg saint maurice
c'est hibernant là ce que l'on a donc
regroupé de force seront les premiers
évacués avec les enfants des classes de
neige dès que la route sera à nouveau
praticable mais vous allez voir dans un
instant ce qui était hier encore cette
route de val d'isère à bourg saint
maurice
cependant dans la soirée après tous ces
travaux le premier convoi pouvait donc
redescendre avec les cercueils avec 200
enfants des classes de neige 200 enfants
encadrés de moniteurs avec aussi
d'ailleurs monsieur marcellin ministre
de l'intérieur bloqué depuis 36 heures
dans la station qui devait ensuite dans
la vallée prendre un avion et atterrir à
minuit à villacoublay
vraiment c'était une catastrophe qui
était imprévisible cette avalanche qui a
les avalanches qui sont prévisibles
celle là ne l'était pas lemay et actions
pour moi c'est la conviction même
commission denquête va étudier les
frères mais le maire qui occupe ses
fonctions de conseiller municipal et de
mer depuis 1934 qui connaît bien la
station et qui parle sous le contrôle de
ce qu'ils m'ont élu génère de la
population déclare ça n'était pas du
tout prévisible
il avait d'ailleurs faire un plan de
lutte contre les avalanches et un plan
pour créer une série d'équipements mais
il n'avait pas prévu ce coin là parce
que personne dans la région de ne
prévoyait que deux là pourrait venir
d'une avalanche aussi meurtrière aussi
terrible c'est ce qui prouve que il y a
des choses sont imprévisibles dans ces
catastrophes
alors évidemment il ya des des
conseillers de la dernière heure qui une
fois la catastrophe est arrivée viennent
dire il fallait faire si aller vers ça
et je ne le vois il occupe des fonctions
qui lui permettent de liliane ou
responsables ces conseils là il fallait
que vous
veniez à vente après de nombreux efforts
de tête pf est surtout à mon avis les
efforts doivent être faits en ce qui
concerne l'implantation des bâtiments
il y a beaucoup de hardiesse
actuellement et il faudrait que cela
soit certainement modéré faudrait
beaucoup plus d'études
lorsqu'il n'y a pas eu de catastrophe
depuis longtemps il y a trop d'audace et
il faut que les contrôles soient
certainement beaucoup plus strictes là
où il doit être fait monsieur marcellin
été reçus ce matin par le président de
la république monsieur georges pompidou
il l'a fait par des constatations qui
l'a fait sur place à val d'isère et il a
annoncé également qu'une commission
denquête ce créneau mais c'est ce qu'il
vient de dire donc un jean-pierre sauter
d'autre part c'est aujourd'hui la
rentrée pour les élèves de la zone à
même les élèves qui étaient à val
d'isère en classe de neige ils sont
arrivés ce matin à la gare de lyon à
paris et nous allons les retrouver là
bas en compagnie de jean-pierre sauter
nous revenons de val d'isère le convoi
s'est très bien passé ça a pris deux
heures on est arrivé en bas et de suisse
on a eu un train et le voyage s'est très
bien passé il n'y a rien eu de vahid
ennuis est-ce que tu as eu peur quoi moi
spécialement pas tellement pas tellement
parce que j'étais pas tellement
concernés mais c'était très mouvementée
mais on était plus haut à folle et on
n'était pas dire qu'on avait peur quoi
on se rentrait pas on fera des pas très
bien compte de la situation on était
plutôt inconscient si tu devais raconter
de menthe à la saison de ski en fin de
semaine de ce qui attend professeur dans
une rédaction qu'est ce que tu lui dirai
vaincu et un bal d'hiver et fut comme
une avalanche sur tout et puis qu'on a
été évacué de notre hôtel on a eu du mal
à trouver des chambres
ça m'a impressionné c'est tout ce
remue-ménage de ces jours ci a pu
sociaux ne sait jamais si c'est ton
enfant de trotel tu as eu peur toi qu on
s est dit nous évacuer oui les deux
autres hôtels doit passer de bonnes
vacances il s'est bien amusé je suis si
on a raconté à paris qu'il faisait
mauvais là haut c'est vrai je serai en
fait et c'est le tueur souvenir que tu
fait de tes vacances
oui la tempête seulement tu n'as pas
fait ce qui a aussi aidé boule de neige
qui a joué quand même si donc passer de
bonnes vacances riches
comment se sont passés vos vacances va
très bien au fait il faisait pas très
beau mais les premiers jours ça allait
mais je viens toujours il y avait
beaucoup de vent mais la face devant
s'élever
alors on peut presque pu faire des skis
je te vois trop ennuyer non ce sont tout
de même de bonnes vacances eux et nous
en garde
oui si à paris on a dit qu'il faisait
pas beau là où c'est vrai oui et du
mauvais temps oui est ce que ça t'a
empêché de t'amuser non pas du tout à
quoi tu as joué je vous rappelle ses
enfants revenaient de val d'isère la
météorologie ne signale que dans les
pyrénées
les conditions atmosphériques sont
maintenant favorables au déclenchement
des avalanches suite du mauvais temps
tempête en bretagne et dans l'atlantique
trois bateaux sont en détresse neige ce
matin dans la région parisienne le
niveau de la seine monte à nouveau et il
est probable que la rive express la voie
express sur la rive droite sera fermé
dans l'après midi
le plus étonnant c'est que dans le même
temps il ya des incendies de forêts dans
le sud de la france et oui
tempête de neige sur les alpes
inondations dans une partie de la france
vous rask sur les côtes
mais la nature a ses caprices sur la
côte d'azur des incendies de forêt sont
attisées par un vent violent reçu de
tourrettes sur loup les pompiers aidés
par des dizaines de bénévoles ont lutté
pendant quatre jours contre l incendie
de forêt et de broussailles hier à
l'aube le sinistre était maîtrisé mais
les pompiers restent très vigilants
des centaines d'hectares de pins et de
broussailles ont été dévorés par les
flammes mais heureusement aucune
habitation n'a été touchée et on ne
signale pas de victimes
nouvelle de l'université maintenant
c'était ce matin à paris la réouverture
de la faculté de droit du d'assas geek
l'est se trouvent sur place et il va
nous dire tout du moins je l'espère
comment cette rentrée s'est passée à
vous hitler bien vous pouvez constater
qu'il ya du monde à la faculté de droit
de la rue d'assas la rentrée dans
l'ensemble s'est effectuée dans le calme
il a par un incident en début de la
matinée à l'ouverture des portes quand
un groupe d'étudiants a voulu distribuer
un tract la direction de
l'administration essayer de s'y opposer
le directeur d'administration monsieur
pas ça a été un peu bousculée enfin
depuis eh bien depuis les choses se sont
arrangées on on discute dans les
couloirs on distribue des tracts d'une
petite gerd affiche chaque groupement a
inscrit ses slogans sur les murs
voyez ça va ça vient à chaque porte on
est un peu filtré par les distributeurs
de tracts
une petite provision moi même votre
petit meeting improvisé dans le grand
hall
ça discute c'est calme ya souvent des
étudiants de tendances opposées
d'ailleurs d'extrême gauche extrême
droite on ne sait pas trop mais enfin
aujourd'hui on discute
les examens partiels ont été renvoyées à
plus tard et comme tout le monde
personne n'en voulait ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre et bien ça a contribué
certainement à faire que cette rentrée
ce matin a été à peu près calme
étudiants qui attendent on ne sait pas
trop ce qu'ils attendent là d'ailleurs
ils regardent les affiche pas
d'installer y avait des cours du reste
dans le grand amphithéâtre y avait
environ 200 étudiants qui suivait un
cours ça s'était passé sans histoire
voilà le mrhc le mouvement pour le
retour en arrière l'humour ne perd
jamais tout à fait ses droits et les
voir l'essai roupiller les étudiants
pourquoi pas à ceux qui étaient là sont
venus un peu travailler quand même
peut-être je sais pas vous m'entendez la
jeunesse
est-ce que vous m'entendez je vous
entends bien oui vous êtes des nouvelles
pour les examens partiels je vois qu'ils
sont reportés ils sont importés oui
c'est ce que je vous ai dit les
étudiants quel de quelque bord qu'il
soit n'en voulait pas et finalement ils
ont été reportés en principe à une
quinzaine d'enfants d'ici là il peut se
passer tellement de choses on ne sait
pas quand ils auront lieu en mai de son
côté l'administration de la faculté a
décidé de porter plainte à la suite de
l'incident qui a opposé ce matin
monsieur passer à un groupe d'étudiants
d'actions françaises
voilà pour l'actualité universitaire le
judiciaire maintenant georges walter
vous revenez du procès douanes soit
clair il a été condamné à 12 ans je
crois de récuser 12 ans de réclusion
criminelle
maître soulez larivière au commencement
certaines houari rappelait ce que
guillaume a avait dit avait écrit à
saint-exupéry ce que j'ai fait aucune
bête ne l'aurait fait et je crois que
c'est une phrase qui caractérise assez
bien le destin de ce ranch faulkner
totalement qui fréquente l'école
communale à paris pendant la guerre
pendant l'occupation et qui est artiste
de cirque avec ses parents ses deux
trios voltaïque hall thaïs et puis ses
parents sont des résistants sont
s'introduisent dans l'administration
allemande de l'occupation à paris et
font partie de cet orchestre rouge de ce
plus fameux des réseaux de résistants
d'origine soviétique pendant la guerre
qui a coûté deux cent mille hommes à la
wehrmacht qui a fait un travail
considérable
pourquoi est-ce que randy wolf mr a fini
par échouer vingt ans après à paris et
pour être accusés
et d'intelligence avec une puissance
étrangère et bien tout simplement parce
que pendant ce temps là un certain le
mans faux journalistes faux homme
d'affaires avait créé un petit réseau
assez minable assez lamentable à l'aide
de sa soeur et d'une dame danilo qui
était secrétaire aux affaires étrangères
seulement comme a dit m tixier
vignancour manger à tous les râteliers
mais peu et pas tous les jours seulement
meurt en 1969 et en dessous volts nerfs
qui lui en allemagne a commencé à mener
une vie normale après des années passées
dans des camps et qui a connu la torture
qui a connu la faim la soif la maladie
qui a eu un destin extraordinaire est
envoyé à paris parce qu'ils avaient à
faire à paris comme directeur des
agences de voyages de l'allemagne de
l'est est chargée de reprendre contact
avec ce réseau c'est là qu'il est arrêté
par la dst eh bien m joe et norman qui
le défend des a eu beau faire une très
belle plaidoirie
il a eu beau évoquer le passé de ce
petit allemands qui étaient à l'école
communale en france il a eu beau
rappeler que les tortionnaires des
parents de ran soltner ceux qui ont fait
décapité sa mère à la che sont restés en
place qu'ils se portent bien qu'ils ont
même collaborer avec les services de
l'otan avec les services alliés
puisqu'ils sont en place dans les
services de renseignement en allemagne
de l'ouest
il a eu beau remuer toutes les émotions
des résistants car il y avait des
résistants dans le tribunal qui
assiégeait ce matin armes soldats a été
condamné il a été condamné
durement sa seule consolation peut être
la dernière
au cours de cette lamentable affaire
c'est peut-être à la manière dont il a
été traité par cette cour c'est une
manière qui ne rappelle en rien celles
qu'ont connues aux tribunaux nazis ses
parents et sa famille et bien rame sur
le tonnerre va continuer à vivre
peut-être pendant 12 ans peut-être moins
dans cet univers absurde où il est né et
où ce même mécanisme ne s'arrêtera
jamais pour lui merci georges walter
situation inquiétante au proche orient
on apprend ce matin que cinquante
ouvriers égyptiens ont été tués lors
d'un raid lors d'un raid de bombardement
de l'aviation israélienne sur une usine
de métallurgie à ce sujet une réaction
de tel aviv
les israéliens disent que la version
israélienne a reçu l'ordre de nouveau
bombardé que des objectifs militaires on
reconnaît toutefois tel aviv que le raid
d'aujourd'hui a été particulièrement
violent et on rappelle que le communiqué
publié à cette occasion parler de
nombreux coups directs but qui avait pu
être constaté par les pilotes
au caire on précise que cinquante
ouvriers ont été tuées et soixante neuf
autres blessés c'est le bilan exact
connu jusqu'à présent de ce raid selon
le porte-parole du caire
d'autre part l'aviation israélienne a
effectué deux autres raids de
bombardement ce matin on ignore s'il ya
des victimes et des dégâts en jordanie
on signale de nouveaux accrochages entre
les forces officielles entre l'armée
jordanienne et les fedayin il semble
qu'elle aura eu sein et beaucoup de mal
à faire admettre aux organisations de
résistance palestinienne les mesures
réglementant leurs déplacements à
l'intérieur du territoire jordanien
les autres pays arabes se sont
d'ailleurs déclarés aujourd'hui hostile
aux décisions prises par le roi us a
toujours de l'étranger on va voir une
nouvelle instance jacques chaban delmas
premier ministre a visité ce matin à
aubervilliers a visité ce matin à
aubervilliers ainsi que dans les 1er et
2ème arrondissement plusieurs taudis
abritant des travailleurs nord africain
et afrique le premier ministre a annoncé
après cette visite donc des taudis à
aubervilliers dans les 11e et 12e
arrondissements qu'un ensemble de
mesures allaient être prises dans les
meilleurs délais pour créer des foyers
d'accueil afin que les taudis se
résorber au plus tard à la fin de 1972
voilà revenons à l'étranger à londres 18
% seulement des britanniques sont
favorables à l'entrée du royaume-uni
dans le marché commun c'est ce qui
ressort d'un sondage d'opinion publié ce
matin
le sondage indique que 72% des personnes
interrogées sont hostiles à l'adhésion
de la grande-bretagne marché commun 10 %
de ces personnes n'ont exprimé aucune
opinion toujours en bretagne a fait
divers maintenant la suite de la sphère
mackay deux frères d'origine indienne
les frères au zain ont été inculpés hier
par un tribunal de londres du maire
trop de mme adam mckay les deux
ravisseurs sont aussi inculpés d'avoir
tenté d'extorquer un million de livres
de rançon à la famille de la victime
il semble bien qu'une machette trouvait
au domicile de mme adam mckay a pris
seul enlèvement et mis les policiers sur
la trace des deux frères originaires de
la trinité mais ce meurtre demeurent
toujours sans cadavre et les forces de
police continuent à fouiller chaque
pouce de la ferme où vivait les deux
frères
la police doit décider aujourd'hui à
l'issue d'un véritable conseil de guerre
si elle abandonne ou non les recherches
l'inculpation des deux frères ne sera
pas la première prononcée en angleterre
alors qu'on n'avait pas retrouvé le
corps de la victime
si on était sportive maintenant avec
michel drucker les skieurs se repose de
val gardena
oui à val gardena l'estuaire se repose
aujourd'hui avant d'entamer les trois
derniers jours de compétition et pendant
que ses champions reprenne des forces
les journalistes ont déjà un premier
bilan après trois épreuves qui sont le
summum spécial masculin le géant
masculin la descente dames c'est la
france et l'autriche qui arrive en tête
avec 3 médailles chacune la suisse vient
ensuite avec deux médailles devant les
états unis
une médaille pour ceux qui aiment les
chiffres qui veulent mettre leur fiche à
jour car je sais qu'elle était
spectateur qui fit de très près ces
championnats du monde
ces victoires se répartissent de la
façon suivante pour la france une
médaille d'or celle de jean noël augert
obtenus dans le slam spéciale de
d'argent russell brand spéciales et
miran descendre pour l'autriche
une médaille d'or karl schranz en géant
une d'argent bla nerfs en géant une de
bronze à marie preuve hier dans la
descente pour la suisse une médaille
d'or and roses riblier en descente et
une d'argent giovanoli en géant enfin
les états unis ont obtenu une médaille
de bronze avec billy king dans le slalom
spécial
comme vous le voyez cette répartition
provisoire et partiel est pour l'instant
bien différente de celle des
championnats du monde de portillo chili
en 66 où la france avait raflé toutes
les médailles le programme des prochains
jours demain spéciale dames les espoirs
français reposent sur jacques coste
horaires femmes hausse et une grille de
la ford
samedi le géant dames avec jacko et
maquis demain enfin dimanche enfin ce
sera le dernier jour la descente avec un
super favori car chance il ya aussi le
titre du combiné qui se calculent vous
le savez sur les trois épreuves
et là deux hommes font figure de favoris
patrick russel de français et le suisse
doumecq jeux vanoc au sujet de la
descente
masculine une dépêche c'est un coup dur
pour l'équipe d'allemagne
franck fogler le skieur allemand bien
connu qui était l'un des favoris avec
france 2 la descente de dimanche est
tombée ce matin en repérant la piste il
a fait une chute à 250 mètres du départ
une chute assez grave
il souffre d'une profonde coupure à la
jambe les dirigeants allemands n'ont pas
encore fait connaître le nom de son
remplaçant soit là avant de voir des
images de basket je voudrais vous dire
que le président des états unis richard
nixon est très satisfait des
championnats du monde de val gardena qui
suit quand vous à la télévision et à ce
sujet il a adressé une lettre de
félicitations au président du comité
organisateur des championnats du monde
ça au cours de la dinde une réunion qui
réunissait hier le comité le président
du comité d'honneur des prochains jeux
olympiques qui s'appelle monsieur
schaeffler et qui a proposé justement
c'est pour cela sans doute que monsieur
x on est content car monsieur schaeffler
a proposé la ville de denver dans le
colorado pour l'organisation des jeux
olympiques d'hiver en 76 cela dit nous
changeons maintenant le sujet nous
allons voir des images qui nous est
envoyée par notre station régionale de
lyon qui concerne un match de basket de
coupe d'europe qui a opposé hier soir au
palais des sports de lyon
l'équipe de villeurbanne à l'équipe
yougoslave étoile rouge de belgrade
toujours ici à droite de votre écran
avec des maillots rayés
les joueurs français jouent à gauche
villeurbanne est actuellement 4e du
championnat et reporte tous ses espoirs
cette année sur cette coupe d'europe
qu'ils discutent en compagnie car ce
sont des poules de quatre en compagnie
de moscou varèse belgrade et donc
villeurbanne quatre équipes villeurbanne
a déjà battu varèse il avait été battu
d'un seul point à l'aller contre ces
yougoslave de belgrade 75 76 et hier il
a gagné le très brillante manière à
l'issue d'un match très très serré qui a
enthousiasmé le public de lyon l'équipe
de villeurbanne se présenter avec ses
joueurs habituels gilles petit l'aurait
casteliers durant la nôtre courra pour
ne citer que les principaux ici michel
leray à des meilleurs joueurs de basket
français qui a marqué hier 18 points il
était avec durant le pivot durant le
plus grand joueur de villeurbanne vous
apercevez ici à droite le meilleur
marqueur pour l'équipe française match
très serré à la mi temps 39 partout vous
le voyez rien n'était joué dans l'équipe
yougoslave cap xxie monowitz et joji
qu'on était les meilleurs les deux
premiers ont marqué 17 points vous voyez
ici
simoneau vic
position de la balance sur la balle ni
qui a raté de très peu un panier dunjic
en a marqué 14 match très équilibré
ceux qui aiment les chiffres 32 paniers
sept coups francs pour villeurbanne 32
33 paniers pour belgrade et cette couche
à 40 secondes de la fin 73 partout des
deux équipes étaient à égalité mais
c'est michel leray qui en quelques
secondes va donner à l'équipe française
le panier de la victoire 75-73 dans une
seconde sur cette frappe
voilà villeurbanne est donc qualifié
pour la suite de la compétition mais il
rencontrera le moscou et là ce sera une
autre histoire
voilà je crois que maintenant nous
allons passer à la deuxième partie de ce
journal avec l'acquis d'alex attendez
j'ai encore une marge les pages de
dynamite si vous permettez je vous
disais tout à l'heure qu'il y avait une
patinoire qui s'étaient écroulés dans la
banlieue de rennes sous la violence du
vent il y à quelques minutes
je viens d'apprendre selon les premiers
renseignements qui sont encore vu le
commissariat central de rennes qu'il n'y
aurait pas de victimes dans cet accident
voilà nous allons maintenant aborder la
rubrique magazine de ce télé midi avec
télé fida tv une émission de jacques
nicora